welcome back to the David Pacman show my
final day
sitting in for David while he is away
didn't mean for that to be Dr seussy
it just uh sometimes it happens when
you're
exhausted from trying to keep up the
pace of David Pacman's uh work schedule
which by the way
off the charts my hat is off the hat I
don't wear is off to David for the uh
uh wild wild amount of work that he puts
in not just in video creation but also
the live the streams that he does it's
just it is bananas so you should be very
thankful for Mr Pacman
uh listen if it's not abundantly clear
already that Donald Trump is not
interested in democracy in fact he is a
direct opponent of it then you haven't
been paying enough attention
Donald Trump is in it for himself
whether it be to protect himself from
legal liability in several cases that
have presented themselves uh as a direct
result of his criminality
or just wanting power and to be able to
to glean as much money out of the
presidency uh as he can
and even if it means by force
it means inflaming the passions of
already
violently uh ready to go hordes of
supporters
I don't think I need to but I'm going to
remind you of all many many of the
violent uh things that happen on the
campaign Trail in 2016. his either
condoning or calling for violence
directly
remember these moments
I don't know if I'll do the fighting
myself or if other people will maybe he
should have been roughed up because it
was absolutely disgusting what he was
doing if you see somebody getting ready
to throw a tomato knock the crap out of
him would you seriously like to punch
him in the face I'll tell you
try not to hurt him
if you do I'll defend you in court don't
worry about it
in the good old days this doesn't happen
because they used to treat them very
very rough and when they protested once
you know they would not do it again so
easily we've become weak we become weak
and you know what the audience swung
back
and I thought it was very very
appropriate the audience hit back and
that's what we need a little bit more of
now part of the problem and part of the
reason it takes so long
nobody wants to hurt each other anymore
right I don't know if I would have done
well but I would have been out there
fighting folks
no if I would have done well but I would
have been boom boom boom
do you plan on paying for the legal fees
of this older gentleman in North
Carolina who sucker punched the
protester from what I understand he was
sticking a certain finger up in the air
and and and that is a terrible thing to
do and in front of somebody that frankly
wants to see America made great again
it's possible you could help him with
legal fees if this man needs it
I've actually instructed my people to
look into it yes and that is not even to
mention the violence that took place on
January 6 where Trump incited
whipped his followers his fan base his
his loyal adherence into a frenzy
to the point that they attacked the
United States capital our Temple of
democracy some call it
people died a deadly failed coup attempt
at the hands of Donald Trump
which by the way he's being sued for by
Congress members of Congress right now
and uh former and current police
officers for violating the Ku Klux Klan
act
we witnessed him a gas peaceful
protesters a block away from the White
House violence is order it's it's the
order of the day for Donald Trump
and I think he realizes and many
Republicans realize that his only path
to power it's certainly not through the
popular vote his only path to power is
through violence or the threat of
violence and he wants to prepare his
people for that eventuality he wants to
get them ready
primed for it
and it's he's notching up he's he's
taken it to the next level
he retruths this reposted this
particular message all in truth social
to his millions of followers
then they will have to figure out how to
fight 80 million plus it's not going to
happen again people my age and old will
physically fight for him this time what
we got to lose I'll donate the rest of
my time here on this planet to do it and
I know many many others who feel the
same they've got my six
and we are locked and loaded
Donald Trump retweeted it I mean I say
retweeted because true social is just a
carbon copy ripoff of Twitter
he retrieved it he reposted this to his
millions
this is a tacit endorsement of this idea
we are locked and loaded we have our
Firearms our weapons of war locked and
loaded ready to go and we will
physically fight
to ensure a second term for Donald Trump
foreign
it's crickets certainly crickets from
Republicans
but is this not
incitement to violence
certain Listen
there is no absolute rights people call
themselves Free Speech absolutists or
because even Scalia when he was alive
Antonin Scalia pushed back on absolutism
with rights the Second Amendment for
instance you don't have an absolute
right to any weapon that you'd like
there are limitations
there are limitations to free speech
and this has to be one of them
Adam kinzinger
he tweeted this about it
he said this is sick sick sick is it
even legal to invite this kind of stuff
um and I I would ask the same question
this is not cute this is not Donald
Trump just trying to get clicks this is
real
the same people who would oh this is
they would dismiss this are the same
people who dismissed that there was a a
legitimate domestic terrorist threat
surrounding the Insurrection surrounding
January 6th and look what happened we
can no longer afford to ignore
this
Government Federal officials the
Department of Justice the FBI whomever
please get off of your hands and do
something
the fact that he is the ex-president of
the United States makes it even more of
an obligation on your part
please
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Jesse dollamore sitting in for David
backman while he is away my final day
here with you
listen I talk a lot about Christian
nationalism and the emerging threat the
under talked about and the
under-appreciated threat of white
Christian nationalism in this country it
has been a decades-long priority and
objective to be met by these Christian
nationalists to intertwine themselves
into government in an effort to take
over the government to force their
crypto fascist views on the rest of us
are you Jewish that should concern you
are you a nun you you don't have faith
in whatever religion religious tradition
it should concern you even if you're a
Christian it should concern you
because the flavor of Christianity the
doctrinal
point of view will likely not be the one
you share
and it will be imposed upon you
and there are many I mean we have
several the dozens of members of
Congress who are now vowed Christian
nationalists
who will jettison any adherence any
loyalty
any solemn vow and oath they took to the
Constitution and who cares
because my flavor of Christianity will
rule
it is a dominionism you should research
and
I'm going to play this clip of this
Jason rapert former Arkansas state
legislator
uh Pastor who is instructing
his audience to that that we must take
authority over the government do you
think that America is going to be free
with a bunch of drag queens running the
place
it is fear-mongering
but it is a call to action this isn't
passive uh well if you know if if we end
up with the majority maybe we can do
some good this is an active movement to
overtake the government and Rule
watch this clip from uh Jason rapert
we must take authority
God told us to go out there and
be be fruitful multiply
fill the Earth subdue it
and have dominion over everything
fill the Earth
subdue it
to take authority
and friends the reason the country is
struggling the reason you've got 32
trillion dollars in debt No No Holds
Barred the reason we come to the
brinksmanship over and over again on the
national debt is because the Christians
in America have failed to take authority
and now is the time to choose
now is the time to stand
now is the time to plan now is the time
to fight now is the time to to work
together
to save the country
look do you think that America is going
to be free with a bunch of drag queen's
running this place no
do you think America can remain free and
strong with a bunch of antifa nuts
running around destroying property no
and if you're tired of that stuff then
it's time to make a change this is a
nation of the People by the people and
for the people
it was created for you to be in charge
a nation of the People by the people and
for the people so when we have
politicians and elected officials that
are corrupt they need to be taken out
send them to jail send them to prison
just like I've seen some people do even
while I was serving in the Arkansas
legislature
when you see people like Joe Biden
taking taking advantage of position and
enriching his family like he has done
it's time to take them out
take them out
remove them
move them on
it's time to take authority
it's time to take authority over
everything in the earth to make a
difference
of for and by the people
this country was made for you
and he's talking to his Christian
audience this country was built for them
they need to take it back and rule the
country
that we have a struggling Nation we have
a 32 trillion dollar debt
doesn't mention anything about 25
percent of that 32 trillion being Donald
Trump's responsibility
doesn't talk about uh unpaid for tax
cuts that led to
that 25 share that stake of our national
debt talks about Jaylene Joe Biden for
corruption but ignores the rampant
flagrant Corruption of Republicans
because they're Christians they are
white Christians who also share in his
dominionism
and his Outlook
subdue the Earth
are we going to be a free country with
drag queens run in the place
antifa
with anti-fascist activists out there
that are are they taking away Freedom
are drag queens taking away your freedom
do you feel less free today because
drag queens read stories to children and
libraries
Jason rapert thinks so
it's dangerous
and it's not French
it's not French this is this is becoming
more and more commonplace more accepted
by virtue of it becoming more
commonplace
and it is something that not only we
need to keep our eye on but we need to
be ready to combat it where it is
to prove that this white Christian
nationalism isn't just a fringe element
in America today I want to play you this
Steve Bannon clip where he has this
this ding dong on
I mean Steve Bannon is mainstream
republicanism
and there's a melding of politics and
religion in a way that we've not seen it
yet before
where they're blending religion and
politics and conspiracy
to try to tap in to that emotional
spiritual belief system of the base
and here is Steve Bannon talking with
this gentleman
about spiritual warfare again I'm I come
from this religious tradition
Evangelical white Christian nationalism
and uh there's there's a there's a a
scripture that's commonly repeated about
we fight not against flesh and blood but
against principalities and powers and
spiritual wickedness in high places I
was raised in a church that believes
there's actual demonic and Angel Warfare
invisibly taking place all around you
then if you can see into the spirit
world you'd be able to witness it's like
the movie Constantine or something this
is what I was taught this is what I
believed until I started reading books
and this is what Steve Bannon is
paddling as a mainstream Republican with
a large platform watch this clip
are we in a spiritual war
one thousand percent
um I that that's exactly why we're doing
this I think that you know it says in
the Bible you know battle isn't against
flesh and blood and I can tell you I
come to DC quite often and uh today we
were worshiping actually on the Rotunda
floor inside of the Capitol and you can
feel it man it's like a real it's a real
battle it's a real spiritual battle that
we're in and I think it's time to when
you say you guys feel it what do you
mean by that you can feel I can feel
that things have changed I'm actually
really optimistic
um tell people that because they need to
hear that yeah I am I am I mean we've
been doing stuff listen we had the we've
had the largest gathering uh in the
church in Washington DC for the last
three years in a row we've had it on the
National Mall
um and it's been it's it's been
difficult you know the last two years
especially
um not just the permitting and the
process and jump through all the Hoops
but spiritually it's it's you felt a lot
of resistance there's like an approach
there's like there's a heaviness there's
a way there's a heaviness in this town
but something happened with this whole
regime change in the house and I don't
even know I'm still like processing it
but today I was walking through the
capitol with my guitar we are worshiping
we're singing no one was stopping us
there was no red tape it's definitely a
new day here you can feel it we only got
a couple minutes so I need people to
because I try to tell people this there
was there was like this heavy blanket
there was something on top of this it
was a spiritual Force yeah that was
pressing things down it's not all the
way lifted yeah but you definitely you
can definitely feel that there's an
energy here that was not here before
yeah there's a crack there's there's
starting to be I feel like we're coming
into a season where it's like there's
some light breaking through you know and
it's enough to actually give a lot of
Hope and um you know we've had we've
been meeting with members today of
Congress senators and and everyone has
this kind of expectation about this
unless you think that this is just a
one-off Steve Bannon needs to fill some
air time and create some content for the
base I submit to you this
Newsmax interview same day likely within
just a few minutes of this taking place
where Newsmax interviews some Wingnut
who's talking about again linking
politics and spiritual warfare that
ancient gods are now attacking the it is
the same network that Republicans are
are are all in a Twist about a t no
longer Distributing
is airing this nonsense again
mainstreaming linking politics and
spiritual warfare
yeah yes what you'll even it's behind
cancel culture it's behind wokism it's
behind what's happening to our public
even Supreme Court decisions even like
the last three Supreme Court decisions
that that linked up with marriage or
sexuality all of them took place on an
exact same date linked to a pagan age
encounter just just a little while back
Chris you know that the president had a
gathering at the White House
um basically you know to call the
respect for Marriage Act supposedly but
it's basically striking down marriage as
we know it um and he lit up the White
House that are in the colors of the
rainbow well there is one of these Gods
I speak about the dark Trinity and that
was in ancient times it's back one of
them is called the Transformer and this
is a this is a a God or Spirit from
ancient times that actually said it has
the power it's a she has the power to
turn a man into a woman a woman into man
blend the lines of gender blend the
lines of male and female well it's
happening right now she actually had an
ancient priesthood that dressed up with
men dressing up as women this is what is
being championed by the government right
now it's championed on our children she
actually had some of her pre-surgically
transition well this spirit is in our
culture and I'm just going to give you a
quick taste as we I'm sure we don't have
time but here's the thing what she
actually was the gods of God of parade
so we have parades she paraded men
dressed up as women we got it back she
actually claimed one time of the year
for possession of the culture and you
know what the time was June so it's back
also had one sign particular was the
sign of the rainbow so this is big it's
affecting all of us and yes it's
affecting the culture and as you said
it's happening in rapid rapid
progression and and it's accelerating
even to this day
so what that beard with the face stapled
to it is talking about is linked to this
kind of stuff
spiritual warfare because there's a
statue
and they're linking politics and the
fight ahead and I believe what they're
attempting to do is really connect to
the base and the conspiracy elements
that surround this particular Faith
tradition
and it's being mainstreamed by Steve
Bannon and Jason rapert and
whoever this knucklehead is
it's dangerous you need to be paying
attention to this because this is only
going to get worse
before it gets better
more
on this Christian nationalism this
bigotry run amok and using the Bible to
justify their bigotry
I played for you yesterday
a clip of Pastor Andrew Brunson
at the national gathering for prayer and
repentance you know where Kevin McCarthy
prayed over a bunch of Congress people
who are literally crying and weeping for
forgiveness about the evils of America
and there's a line in there
that Brunson uses talking about a
millstone
a scripture in the Bible Matthew
chapter 18 I think
where Jesus says something oh I'm going
to paraphrase not much of a Jesus quota
but you
have me
it's something about that
that enter if you cause a child to sin
or fall away from from following Jesus
it's better to have a millstone a
massive rock that would Mill wheat
tied around your neck and have you
thrown to the Bottom of the Sea
execution
that it's better for that to happen than
for you to cause a child to stray from
Christ
and Brunton used that line
and to prove more evidence more points
about Christian nationalism being
dangerous and this spiritual warfare
element and melding politics and
religion there's a congressman a a state
legislator
in Oklahoma who just is introducing the
millstone Act
and I want to read about that but
firstly I'll give you the Refresher
on Brunson and his prayer at the
national gathering for prayer and
repentance
I believe that we are in danger of
judgment as a nation especially because
we have become the primary corrupter of
the world
and particularly of Youth and children
our government and corporations
increasingly March under the rainbow
flag
we bully weaker and poorer countries to
come under that flag our University's
trained millions of foreign students who
returned to their countries with this
ideology our social media and
entertainment companies make it
attractive they promote they normalize
celebrate immorality
and there's no escaping them as a
blanket the world
they're Godly mothers and fathers around
the world who fear our influence and
sometimes when I'm in a foreign country
I want to fall on my knees and repent
for what we are doing to these countries
to these people
Jesus said woe to the ones to the one
who causes others to sin
and he underlines us especially in
relation to the young whoever causes one
of these little ones to sin it would be
better for him if a millstone were hung
around his neck and he were drowned in
the depth of the sea
he's low-key in a milk toast way talking
about execution
and again you may think he's a fringe
character you might think he's a nobody
you've never heard of
you might think he has no power other
than influence of a congregation
but he influences people who do have a
say
the Congress people in that room who
prayed with him and over him
and people like this legislator
in Oklahoma
David Bullard
I'm going to read a little bit from
Andrew Seidel wrote this piece talking
about this and I think it's poignant and
I hope that it will illuminate some
things for you if you are not quite on
board with exactly how dangerous and
present this threat is
the article here Christian nationalist
legislator introduces anti-trans
Millstone act suggesting biblical
retribution
a Biblical death sentence in America in
2023 a legislator has proposed the
millstone act which he openly confesses
quote was named in reference to Matthew
18 6 but whoever causes one of these
little ones who believe in me to sin it
is better for him to have a heavy
Millstone be hung around his neck and
that he be drowned in the depths of the
sea
America embraced the separation of
church and state as a core fundamental
value precisely to prevent religious
despots from abusing government power to
impose their personal religion on all of
us but Oklahoma State Senator David
Bullard is a Christian nationalist out
to make Oklahoma into a Christian state
forged in the fires of Oklahoma State
Senator David bullard's violent
Christian imagery this bill is one of a
horde of anti-trans bills sweeping our
country bullard's Bill purports to
protect children while threatening
medical professionals it declares a
state of emergency and bans gender
affirming care in the name of bullard's
God as with other such bills it
dehumanizes and demonizes trans people
unlike other bills Bullard christened
his with a Biblical name that threatens
that promises violence and death
again
this is mainstreaming and you may live
in California or New York or
Massachusetts or here in Washington DC
and you think ah I live in a liberal
Library area this will never happen
but there are hundreds of millions of
Americans who live in red States who are
under the thumb of despots just like
this if you think there are no Democrats
in Oklahoma who will be under the thumb
of this you're wrong if you don't think
there's millions of Democrats in Texas
where they will copy this
you're wrong Christian nationalist
politicians have almost nothing to offer
their constituents other than the bitter
sectarianism of Christian nationalism
the Republican Takeover in Congress
which is focused on Petty retribution
pointless and performative
investigations and possibly cratering
the global economy proves the point
instead of doing good such politicians
seek to strip women and minorities of
every protection support Aid assistance
and basic dignity and then call
themselves pro-life
they'll gladly enact policies that
dramatically increase infant mortality
and thrust millions of children into
poverty while claiming to care about
Children's Health they fetishize their
guns muellishly clutching the
instruments of the leading cause of
death for America's children with an
unrivaled passion they rail against
life-saving vaccines and masks and the
scientific consensus behind them while
the covet pandemic is also among the top
10 killers of our children and then
brimming with arrogance and utterly
lacking self-knowledge they have the
gall to propose legislation that amounts
to a death threat against those who
would harm children another line from
The Book of Matthew comes to mind you
hypocrite first take the plank out of
your own eye
Andrew Seidel
and if you think it's just Fringe it's
just a state guy he doesn't really have
much influence or power over the rest of
us
think again because Matt Walsh just
yesterday
the daily wires Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro's
little bearded lap dog
called for the execution of doctors
who provide gender affirming care
Trump also says as he goes on to say
that the that he would direct the
Department of Justice to investigate
hospitals pharmaceutical companies uh
doctors to find out if they've been
involved in a cover-up of the horrific
long-term side effects uh and of gender
transition drugs and surgeries and the
answer of course is that yes they have
been covering those things up as any
genuine and thorough investigation will
clearly show which is why the next step
under a trump Administration or any
Republican Administration should be to
arrest the culprits the um hundreds and
hundreds of them if not thousands of
them and throw them in federal prison
now this can be a matter of simple fines
and financial penalties I mean that
should be part of it
but uh the only real recourse here the
only semblance of Justice would be
prison sentence is very long ones
now if it were up to me we you know we'd
go further than that as far as I'm
concerned mutilating and castrating
children should be legally considered a
capital crime and it should earn the
prescribed penalty for such crimes but
if we can't have that then prison will
have to suffice
this is where we are in America in 2023.
so I would assume there are many out of
you out there who are organizers who are
activists who care about the direction
that our country is taking
and this isn't just about budget battles
we are and this is not hyperbolic we are
in it for the fight for the soul of our
nation are we a nation of equality and
acceptance and diversity
or are we a country of white Christian
nationalism and oppression
that's the question
and are you ready
because it's only going to get worse
before it gets better
I'd love to have you subscribe to my
YouTube channel dollar more daily here
on YouTube you can find my podcast
anywhere podcasts are found it's called
I doubt it with my lovely talented and
scholarly co-host Brittany page and of
course you can follow me on social media
and you tell me how wrong I am there I
am at dollymore on Twitter tick tock and
Instagram
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the David Pacman show I am Jesse
dollar more filling in for my final day
for David while he is away
well they did it House Republicans with
their new majority voted ilhan Omar off
the Foreign Affairs committee gleefully
they did it they did it while
putting Marjorie Taylor green back
on
committees they did it while Lauren
bobert holds a spot on the house
oversight and accountability committee
they did it while Paul gosar and a vowed
white nationalist
also has committee here uh assignments
and Democrats showed up in force to
support congresswoman ilhan Omar I'm
going to play three clips for you one is
Eric swalwell
genius points
one is AOC who talks about the rampant
and rank hypocrisy of Republicans who
act like they're in it to to curb
anti-Semitism which is nonsense because
Kevin McCarthy just tweeted this a few
months ago
we cannot allow Soros and stire in
Bloomberg to buy this election get out
and vote Republican November 6th Maga
with a a grainy picture of the
Jewish George Soros
so it is not in good faith or believable
or reputable in in any way shape or form
that this is about combating
anti-Semitism in the Congress so if that
were the case Paul gosar would not have
a job Marjorie Taylor green would not
have a job and
dare say Kevin McCarthy would not have a
job here's Eric swalwell making some
Salient points gentlemen is recognized
for one minute
Madam speaker when I heard that we're
going to remove a member of this house
from their committee for anti-Semitism I
raced down here because I thought
finally finally in this chamber there's
going to be some accountability some
accountability from this conference that
continues to allow its members to root
for rioters
to show sympathy for the Insurrection a
conference that Harbors a wanted
international criminal
and has members who choose violence over
voting every single day finally and so I
thought we're going to hold someone
accountable for anti-Semitism surely
it's the author of this tweet Kanye Elon
Trump October 6 written by chairman Jim
Jordan October 8th what does Kanye say
I'm going to declare Defcon 3 on the
Jews so surely this tweet came down
right came down was deleted no two more
months it was kept up two more months
so don't come here looking at us for
anti-Semitism look in your own damn
mirror before you ever come over here
and I yield back
where is he wrong
how is he wrong
Jim Jordan has his little special burner
account that happens to be the house
Republican Judiciary Committee Twitter
account
Kanye Elon Trump
whether trolling or not they're
promoting
a a a vile anti-semite
AOC equally fired up someone who's been
uh threatened by anti-semites
in the house not because of religion
but these vile actors these Bad actors
within the Republican Party
Marjorie Taylor green Paul gosar who
depicted her death
are still on highly sought after
committees watch AOC
all right gentlewoman is recognized for
one minute
thank you now as also as a fellow New
Yorker I think one of the things that we
should talk about here is also one of
the disgusting Legacy after 9 11 has
been the targeting and racism against
Muslim Americans throughout the United
States of America and this is an
extension of that Legacy consistency
there is nothing consistent with the
Republican parties continued attack
except for the racism and incitement of
violence against women of color in this
body I had a member of the Republican
caucus threaten my life and you all and
the Republican caucus rewarded him with
one of the most prestigious committee
assignments in this Congress don't tell
me this is about consistency don't tell
me that this is about an ABS a
condemnation of anti-semitic remarks
when you have a member of the Republican
caucus who has talked about Jewish based
lasers and an entire amount of tropes
and also elevated her to some of the
highest committee assignments in this
body this is about targeting women of
color in the in the United States of
America don't tell me because I didn't
get a single of time has expired my life
was threatened thank you
and crickets from Republicans
pushing forward
to vote her off committees and this is
this is racism
this is fear of other this is anti-black
is what this is
anti-immigrant anti-woman
as ilhan Omar herself will explain she
got the last word in this before the
vote I guess you got the second to last
word since Republicans did get the last
word I talked about this the other day
that it was a foregone conclusion that
this was going to happen
and now it has but before it did
ilhan Omar did get to speak
this debate today
it's about who gets to be an American
what opinions do we get to have do we
have to have to be counted as Americans
this is what this debate is about Madam
speaker
there is this idea that you are suspect
if you are an immigrant or if you are
from certain parts of the world or a
certain skin tone or a Muslim it is no
accident that members of the Republican
Party accused the first black President
Barack Obama of being a secret Muslim
it is no accident that former president
Donald Trump let a birther movement that
falsely claimed he was born in Kenya
because to them
falsely labeling the first and only
President of the United States of
America a Muslim an African immigrant
somehow made him less American
well
I am Muslim
I am an immigrant and interestingly from
Africa
is anyone surprised that I am being
targeted
is anyone surprised that I am somehow
deemed unworthy to speak about American
foreign policy
or that they see me as a powerful voice
that needs to be silenced
frankly it is expected because when you
push power power pushes back
representation matters
continuing to expand our ideas of who is
American
and who can partake in the American
Experience experiment is a good thing
I am an American
an American who was sent here
an American who was sent here by her
constituents to represent them in
Congress a refugee who survived the
horrors of a civil war someone who spent
her childhood in a refugee camp
none of that matters to Republicans
Republicans who prattle on about the
American dream and quote Reagan about
being a shining city on a hill
and yet they punish and ostracize and
oppress a member of their own body
because she's black she's Muslim
and she's a a former refugee
who became a citizen who him who should
to them embody the American dream
if they weren't vile pernicious
Hypocrites that is
let's talk a little bit more about Kevin
McCarthy
the circus-like atmosphere that has been
created by the Republican party uh is is
something to behold they're they're
they're ushering in their power by him
being peppered with questions constantly
everywhere he goes setting up little
impromptu uh oppressors
being asked questions and he posted this
I guess in response to a question where
he has his little canned response in
order to create a sound bite
and he was so proud of this that he
tweeted this along with a video he
tweeted 100 Democrats just refused to
denounce socialism that's scary and it
explains a lot about why Congress has
been spending so much these last four
years
these last four years odd because Donald
Trump was president in part of that last
four years and in order for Congress to
spend any money again Republicans if
you're watching let me educate you on
how a bill is made
in order for an Appropriations Bill to
get to the president's desk for
Signature it must originate in the House
of Representatives and then it must make
its way through the Senate and then on
to the president's desk in this case
your dear leader Pumpkinhead Donald
Trump who signed it with his Sharpie
so you can't blame this on Democrats
these budgets were approved of
by a Republican president
and as far as socialism being scary
what would you have us do Kevin McCarthy
are we going to dispense with Social
Security
are we going to find another way to fund
our Public Schools
or our children millions of children
just to be left to fend for themselves
and educate themselves I mean that that
sounds like a republican Paradise
uh a substandard education for children
so they're not able to think
and reason and make rational decisions
when they become adults
when it's time to vote for someone
here's Kevin McCarthy uh if I had to
watch it you've got to watch it
here's the video that was appended to
this particular tweet
a couple interesting things happen on
the floor right now you had almost if
you combine the number of Democrats who
voted no and voted present there's a
hundred Democrats that won't stand up
against socialism that's a real concern
to me in America today it's not just
that wasn't a college vote on a college
campus that was a vote in the U.S
Congress that 100 Democrats
couldn't say socialism was wrong that's
a scary point of view but you also
understand why we're in a spending
problem that they are when they were in
the majority that's why you understand
the challenges that we have here
so proud of that particular piece of
audio and video that he slapped his logo
on it it's watermarked as his own and he
tweeted it out proudly tweeted that out
what is scary
about socialism
do you think that uh Scandinavia is a is
a is a is a hellscape
they can't pay their bills
are people not free there
socialism if you listen to a republican
is
chaotic States like Venezuela
it's not the the prosperous
States all across the world who have
some semblance of socialism somewhere in
their in their system
much like the United States with Social
Security I mean sounds like Kevin
McCarthy wants some kind of uh dystopic
libertarian hellscape
where you're on your own
you get hurt
you you get disabled you lose your job
ah sorry you're on your own
you have children you want them educated
you're on your own
you retire and you want to live out your
golden years with some safety net
you should have invested more wisely
if you're poor you can't work you can't
find a job you're on your own
all of that
is answered by some level
of socialism
it's not a bad word that Republicans
would have you believe
it's just it's gross and and for in for
Kevin McCarthy's part of it it's just
dumb
because rational reasonable per people
across the country aren't falling for
this
the unfortunate thing is that millions
and millions and millions of Republicans
Fox News Watchers Newsmax Watchers oan
viewers they are falling for it they
think it's self-evident that socialism
is scary
come on
also come on I'd love to see you
subscribe to my YouTube channel to
search my name Jesse dollar more uh I am
also on social media at dollar more
there a lot of dollar more action
related to me oddly enough and I also
host a podcast that doesn't have dollar
more in the title it's called I doubt it
it's co-hosted with me and my lovely
talented and scholarly co-host Brittany
page and we'd love to see you there
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am once again and maybe for the last
time in quite a while Jesse dollar more
sitting in for David Pacman while he is
out hopefully rexing and relaxing and
having a good time with the family
I don't know how many times I've said
this and it gets a little old having to
say it all the time but Republicans are
uh projection artists
they
point the finger and make accusations
about things that they themselves are
guilty of
especially related to voter fraud and
election fraud
how many times have they they
saber-rattled and freaked out about the
widespread issue of voter fraud and then
when you hear about cases of individual
voter fraud that happen it's always a
Republican or some husband who votes for
his dead wife for
some politician whose wife is voting for
him multiple times just over and over
and over and over again they out
themselves as guilty of the same thing
they're accusing everyone else of
and this is really just a ah it's this
is this is Sav for uh for My Wounds this
is this is vitamin for me Kerry Lake now
likely committed a felony breaking
election laws in Arizona
by tweeting out a picture of Voters
signatures
this woman who's been making the rounds
like every other day it seems like she's
at Mar-A-Lago cozying up to Donald Trump
kissing the ass of Donald Trump
promoting him as this great savior
she's talked about herself as Donald
Trump in a dress
not far off
I'm going to read a little bit from this
headline from this local Arizona NBC
affiliate and the the title of which is
looks like a felony elections expert
says Carrie Lake may have gone too far
by tweeting voter signatures and then
laughs and then a little statement from
oan and Trump lawyer Alina Haba who is
just about as uh I mean look if you're
ever in a situation where you're in need
of legal representation please do not
seek out someone as as unprofessional
and uh harebrained as Elena Haba
for the ex-president of the United
States of America to have this woman
representing him on TV and in courtrooms
is just
crazy
so we'll start with the headline here
and the a little bit from this article
looks like a felony elections expert
says Carrie Lake may have gone too far
by tweeting voter signatures for almost
three months Carrie lake has refused to
accept her defeat in the Arizona's
governor race but now Lake may have gone
too far with a tweet
again the parallels between she and
Trump are just rich
that she's in trouble now because of a
tweet
Arizona's top election officer
Democratic Secretary of State Adrian
Fontes has asked Democratic attorney
general Chris Mays to investigate
whether Lake broke the law by posting 16
voter signatures in an image she tweeted
last week
quote Arizona statute is very clear
about when and where a voter signature
can be shared or replicated or
reproduced or put online or used in
social media said Tammy Patrick chief
executive for programs at the National
Association of election administrators
and a form former Maricopa County
elections official quote the answer to
all of those things basically is never
and not and it can't be with very few
exceptions Patrick's opinion of the late
tweet
when I read the law it looks to me like
that's a felony under Arizona law quote
the records containing a voter signature
shall not be accessible or reproduced by
any person other than the voter
a violation of the law is a class six
felony that could carry jail time and
then statement from the Secretary of
State here it is my responsibility to
protect Arizona voters Fontes said the
statement in keeping with my duties I
have referred this matter to the
attorney general
and then here as promised just uh just
uh put just in get it right into your
veins Alina Hava Donald Trump's attorney
making an appearance on oan and just
giving her her legal opinion about the
matter
Lake included a graphic with 16 voter
signatures on the Tweet Fontes cited an
Arizona statute saying that voter
signatures quote shall not be accessible
or reproduced by any person other than
the voter Bob dismissed the letter
labeling it as an intimidation tactic I
think this is a drastic attempt on the
part of Democrats who have forced their
way into office against the will of many
voters who have very serious concerns
about the election in Arizona and I
think this is an intimidation technique
you would think that they would do a
simple cease and desist letter to Carrie
Lake's team saying hey can you please
take that down off of social media we're
concerned about privacy rights but they
went straight to requesting the newly
installed Democrat attorney general to
look into criminal charges against
Carrie lake or her her social media team
for this I mean talk about escalating
something extraordinarily quickly so one
that's not Alina Haba that's Christina
Bob that's another other Trump lawyer
two
she's asking for a cease and desist why
didn't they just say hey stop felony
Quick Quit committing felonies stop the
felonious activity and uh you'll be okay
you already tweeted it you already put
it out there there have already been
screenshots and Reese tweets and all the
shares that take place you committed the
felony you don't get a take back you
don't get a redo when it's a Classics
felony that carries with it possible
jail time
but leave it to a trump lawyer
to make excuses for someone in power it
is just one more case of Republican
projection one more case of Republican
disregard for the law all while
uh attempting to act like they are the
party of Law and Order and blue lives
matter and back the blue and you know
just follow the law it's
all a bit much
listen I want to say thank you for
joining me this week while I sub for
David it has been a good time getting to
uh interact with some of you in the
comments and uh I appreciate you very
much if you would like to stick with me
you can subscribe to my YouTube channel
jessiedollamore or find me on social
media I am at Dollar Moore just about
everywhere you can also check out my
twice weekly weekly podcast called I
doubt it uh co-hosted by myself and the
lovely talented and scholarly Brittany
page we'd love to see you then
foreign